voilà le tour du monde par les trois
caps le cap de bonne espérance en
afrique du sud le 4 le wind en australie
le cap horn en amérique du sud
voilà le tour du monde en moins de 80
jours alors en 93 à vimy 79 jours 1 194
le regretté peter blake avait mis 74
jours en 97 kersauson 71 jours et vous
en 2002 soixante-quatre jours voilà sept
jours de moins que kersauson le premier
sous les 70 jours est ce que la
prochaine fois vous pensez qu'on
arrivera à le faire en moins de 60 jours
ouais je pense que c'est possible mais
tout le monde pense à la barre va monter
on a été les premiers sous 91 pouvoir
mieux 70 sont faits devraient être les
premiers 60 peut-être mais ça va venir
progressivement la technologie ne permet
les avons acquis beaucoup d'expérience
maintenant dans ces nouvelles machines
sont absolument incroyable donc ce qu'il
faut c'est savoir les doser et pas trop
tirer dessus alors car ce sont va
repartir
l'hiver prochain sur geronimo oui
olivier c'est dommage on nous a quittés
en fait l'oeuvre d'euros de prêts
préparait pour un duel un petit peu
petit peu costaud quand même et c'est
pas la première fois qu'on se fait un
duel tous les deux et malheureusement
bon c'est un sport mécanique mais il va
repartir
ouais et si elle nous ravir le trophée
de le ramener le ramener chez lui alors
vous ça mal commencé parce que le 14
février après 25 minutes de course
il ya une rupture de la tête de mât ça
fait désordre ah ouais à l'ag du mal
pour vous vraiment je me dis retour
redépart le 2 mars
et puis ça a continué à le 15 mars une
pièce de métal de 50 cm de long se
détache encore une fois de la tête de
mât s'est fabriqué n'ont cessé de la
super technologique c'est vraiment un
assemblage de 1000 pièces mécaniques
la moindre petite pièce qui lâche
toute la chaîne s'arrête quoi et c'est
là où toute la capacité des hommes et à
résoudre les problèmes est très
importante le prenez pas de savoir si on
va voir des emmerdes aussi on en aura
pas on est sûr d'en avoir fait savoir
sur la foire les réseaux c'est vrai et
c'est ça qui est très un peu la série
gestion alors le 15 mars cinq heures
d'arrêt donc pour réparer quand vous
arrêtez ce en pleine mer c'est comment
oui il faut s'arrêter il faut savoir
lever le pied donné ni hiérarchie de
priorités pour gagner quelque chose la
première chose qu'il faut faire c'est
arrivé ouais donc faut mettre les choses
dans l'ordre comme or le 2 avril
nouveaux problèmes techniques 20 heures
de réparation alors là dans les
conditions extrêmement difficiles
oui je sais pas quand c'était ça devait
au milieu de l'océan indien sans la
notion indien pourri très très difficile
avec des coups de vent assez fort 60 65
degrés et un engin comme ça dans ces
conditions c'est pas très facile donc il
faut encore une fois avant la lucidité
et la prudence de lever le pied de de
s'attaquer aux priorités est de réparer
de repartir derrière et d'attaquer le 11
avril c'est d'électronique qui disjoncte
grave
arrivée des icebergs sur vous ouais mais
ça c'est moins grave non dans
l'électronique
qui en est aucun n'est passé en as une
aide à la navigation à la performance
non faut quand même garder le sens marin
sinon se transforme en robot 15 et le 23
avril donc fissures avaient expliqué
fissures dans la boule de titane sur
laquelle repose le mas vous faites un
pansement carbone en fait c'est un mâle
45 mètres de haut à peu près ça fait à
peu près de tonnes c'est une espèce
d'aile d'avion et ça repose sur une
petite boule en titane puisque le mât
est orienté commune elle les choses plus
performante et cette boule en titane qui
est un métal forcément très précieux et
très solide s'est fêlé sur pratiquement
la moitié donc si la fêlure continue la
boule explosé le matin et il a fallu
réfléchir à deux fois avant de décider
de continuer de s'arrêter alors
navigation sous des murs d'eau carrément
en apnée et alors des ombres en gelée et
alors j'ai appris un truc on pourrait
prendre votre interview c'est que vous
avez des masques de ski commence à se
marrer cette nouvelle dimension en fait
deux
deux bolides en fait battre tellement
qu'on fabrique du vent apparent et même
quand le vent vient de l'arrière par
exemple à 150 degrés le vent apparent
vient en face finalement on va vite on
le fabrique
donc on il faut absolument qu'on se
protège et je suis sûr que la prochaine
génération va y avoir une évolution des
carénages comme en offshore ouais parce
qu'on en apprenne un point la fille on a
des masques de hockey sur glace les
masques de ski là haut quand on emprunte
des ustensiles à d'autres sports
alors qu'on fabrique et notre maintenant
alors maintenant votre objectif c'est de
reis 2004 ans une idée avoue doré c'est
quoi le principe de tes oreilles ce
parce que nous limite ça fait rêver quoi
ouais mais nos limites il peut être
interprété de manière et j'aime pas
l'interprétation du no limit vers
l'extrême je pense pas que c'est facile
mais c'est pas ça qui m'intéresse c'est
ce qui m'intéressait c'est de donner la
liberté à l'homme donner la liberté à
tous les créatifs tous les ingénieurs
tous les grands marins du monde et pour
la première fois de leur dire vous avez
une feuille blanche
faites ce que vous voulez on part tous à
un moment donné une partie de barcelone
on arrive à marseille c'est le tour de
la planète c'est le parcours le plus pur
et c'est la première grande course du
match alliance et loire oui mais surtout
tout est libre il ya la vie est toujours
fait de sueur réglementation des
réglementations et un moment donné il
était temps de libérer les énergies et
ça donnait cette nouvelle génération qui
est absolument fabuleuse donc j'ai pas
couru l'année dernière parce que vous
étiez l'inventaire sept ans de boulot
pourrait remonter le truc et
là j'ai décidé d'essayer de revenir la
compétition et j'ai beaucoup de chance
de revenir si vite
l'objectif c'est d'essayer de gagner la
deuxième édition en 2004 après deux
faciles je suis pas le soleil français